yo we're shooting first we feast
shouting Shawn what up hey what's going
on everybody four first we feast I'm
Sean Evans coming at you from HR on in
Bushwick Brooklyn where I'm joined by
Andrew and David Fung aka the Fung Bros
a YouTube duo that week over week
explores the music cuisine and culture
making waves in Asia and beyond and
that's why we're here at each ear on one
of Japan's most celebrated ramen chains
to explore one of the world's most
treasured cheap eats I'm talking about
the instant noodle we're gonna be
rolling out instant noodles from
distinct regions throughout Asia and
then we're gonna step into each your ons
famous flavor concentration booth to see
how it stacks up to the real McCoy but
first things first you guys spend so
much time in New York and LA spots where
you find great ramen bars everywhere you
look why does the instant noodle hold
such a special place in your guy's heart
man I think instant noodles holds a big
place like everybody's hearts growing up
at some point whether you know you're in
college you know the broke college
student esta that's the story but now
the instant noodle game has changed so
much and has advanced now there's like
bowls there's different oils there's
actual meat in in bowls I think it's a
staple of the American diet I would say
and and the global diet at this point
and I actually think that instant ramen
is a lot of people's initial and maybe
for some people the extent of their
exposure to Asian culture well I could
sit and talk ramen with you guys all day
but the stomachs rumbling it's lunch
time let's bring out the first bowl all
right first up we're gonna start in
China this is a roasted beef flavored
noodle from a brand called UNIF it comes
with powdered seasoning a pack of dried
vegetables and another packet of paste
they are 2 for $3 at Hong Kong
supermarket in Chinatown this says in
Chinese in Mandarin this says homestyle
roam in which is a red braised beef
noodle soup beef noodle soup hugely
popular in China especially Taiwan I
think it's like the Taiwanese national
dish so this is dope
no I would definitely put this in like
the second or third tier of instant
noodles coming up from your cup of
noodles you know which is your base very
Americanized flavor but this has some
kick to it this is pretty good I mean I
would say that not that many people are
familiar with Chinese instant noodles
and the Chinese and Southeast Asian ones
they include the oil packets I love this
all right so you have the green onions
scallions you have the little dried
chilies obviously it's dehydrated when
it gets into hot water it's gonna be all
cooked okay and then you have the feels
like the powder mix you know probably
where you'll find your msg of course the
magic ingredient and then this is the
oil packet now I know some like parents
like my mom or like some older people
might be like I don't eat the oil it's
like not good oil just eat it you're not
in instant noodles every day go for it
make it taste good and this it's our
first one which is a tough thing to rink
because you don't know how it's stacking
up against the other ones but here's
what I'll say I'm trying to save room
but I can't I just keep going for
another bite it's complex it has some
spice to it some smoke I'm giving this a
solid four I don't want a copycat but
I'm going with four two because I
thought on our authenticity level it is
mimicking a bowl of beef noodle soup all
right I was impressed this is my first
time having instant beef noodle soup
that was dry originally so yeah for this
is the man rock ooh Japanese tempura
soba from the brand Hikari miso the soup
is flavored with soy sauce and bonito
stock and the noodles are made from
wheat flour and buckwheat flour the bowl
also gets topped with some crispy
tempura pieces we got these for $2.49
each at sunrise Mart in Manhattan what
do you guys know about this bowl yo um I
know that this is you know when you're
reaching about the 253 dollar range
first of all at certain markets this is
$5 but I think it's almost gonna at a
premium quality manner and here's why
let me pop the top so you got the the
soup base here and then you have the
temperate chip because you're like
because you're like oh how am I gonna
get that temper of flavor in there this
support chip has peas I want to say you
know some onions might even have the
little shrimps inside too
do that shrimp tempura feeling Wow the
bonito flavor Wow
good you know the bonito flakes a little
shrimp the temperature
dude that is gonna weigh no I'm actually
blown away by those boom I would say
almost maybe of the instant noodle game
this might be like a Shake Shack
you know Shake Shack is on a slightly
different price level than everything
else but still kind of considered
fast-food right so that's what this is
okay
the Shake Shack of instant noodles what
are you giving it out of five I'm giving
it a five ooh maybe you don't want a
perfect five I mean they gave you the
chip in it I gotta give it about five
they really do go that extra mile I'm
giving it four point five because we
still have a few bowls to go and I don't
know where my ceiling is I reserve the
right to crank it up at the end but now
it's time to bring out another course
what we have here is the samyang hot
chicken flavor ramen from Korea these
gained popularity in the last few years
because the viral fire noodle challenge
the spiciest variety clocks in at about
eighty eight hundred units on the
Scoville scale this one is about half
that we picked it up for $2.99 at H Mart
in Koreatown what can you tell me about
this all right this is my first time
having this but I can tell you that a
lot of youtubers have made million hit
videos by just trying this in YouTube
noodle this is the YouTube noodle
samyang definitely a guy went to college
with but I shot it to them but the
packaging is very advanced look they got
the QR code they have nice graphics they
actually have a heat sleeve here you
feel it it's got a little like a little
body on the chewy
how many scovilles four thousand you
said 440 I said 4400 tastes more than
44-hundred damn coming from you that's
I'm scared for a second huh oh this is a
very hot cup of noodles right here it's
pretty spicy man but what I can tell you
is that after eating a lot of spicy food
there's different types of spices yeah
was a front spice and a back spice I
want to say this is more of a front
spice right now I feel like it's just
aerating my mouth like I can feel all
the
front things that are in this blend I'm
catching them all they're all hitting me
kind of different it's a full-blown like
empty the clip assaults on the inside of
my mouth right now I determined how hot
it is by just how many times I have to
inhale are you breathe through your
teeth you know you have your own meter
the scovilles for me i just go by the
amount of droplets on my nose so i'm
like okay yeah definitely
there were some perspiration on a scale
from one to five whoo you guys bring in
here I'm giving this a four and a half
this was good I'm gonna give it a a five
just because I'm actually a little bit
lightheaded right now so you know I'm
gonna give it a four point - my mouth is
on fire right now but that doesn't slow
down the Train
one bit because we still have more
noodles to eat next bowl please
last but not least the eat you're on
noodle kit this package seeks to mimic
each Ron's famous pork face ramen it's
often viewed as one of the best instant
noodles in Japan and a 3-pack costs $39
so we are working our way up
you know instant ramen I wonder from you
guys perspective is it supposed to be
cheap or these higher-end luxury premium
kits worth the price sometimes I think
it's worth it it's a rainy day you're in
your apartment you're not heading
whatever 10 20 30 streets in whatever
direction to go get premium ramen you
can have premium ramen that's your house
who said that instant ramen had to be
cheap and I have no doubt that each Iran
did a great job of packaging their soup
and everything you know I can feel it
it's real thick that is the tonkatsu
that I'm used to like a jelly pack
[Music]
oh good good this came out of the bag
you can taste and feel in the quality of
the noodles that we have a major upgrade
compared to what we've eaten today that
is true man we really like the bottom
tier today we went we went from level 2
to 3 to 4 yeah this is men might be
level 5 like this is off this is like
skip the step I mean this is look this
is actually how you can buy a lot of
noodles at the Asian Mart it's a 5 to me
I think it's the best bowl that we've
had today it's a 5 I mean it tastes like
that restaurant quality well we've had
the instant noodles but how do you know
if it stacks up to the real McCoy you
have to go to the solo dining booth
we're gonna have a restaurant Bowl we'll
see how it compares to the instant
noodles we've had today are you
gentlemen ready looking let's do it
all right we've had some of the best
instant noodle brands throughout the
world but how do they stack up to one of
the best chef made bowls of ramen in New
York City here we are on the solo dining
booths the fun grows maybe they hopped
in a car maybe they hopped from the taxi
maybe they're gone I feel totally alone
in the sensory deprivation chamber time
to just dive right in and see how the
instant noodles stack up for the record
we are still here near broke shout out
here I'm just alone in the booth next to
you I'm super excited to try this I've
actually seen this in many YouTube
videos but I have not been in the
sensory deprivation booth myself I just
know things taste better when you're
just concentrated on the food also I
like how the elevation of the table is
closer to your face so you're closer to
the bowl so there's less spillage and
less splattering the thickness of the
tonkatsu is unmatched that heat the
noodles are still different cooked to
perfection oh this is up there in terms
of some of the best that I've ever had
easily
it's not surprising you know like the
difference between making noodles
yourself and going to a good Italian
restaurant you're gonna have a real
change in the dynein experience can
obviously taste the difference and
basically every ingredient hey you know
you could do push-ups and sit-ups in
your house too but it ain't like going
up to Equinox alright and seeing a hot
girl and then all of a sudden you got
your second wind
you got another mile on the treadmill
you got another 25 pounds on the squat
you know that's just life hit the
restaurant splurge a little bit treat
yourself you deserve it well there you
have it the ramen Commandments and if
you heard it from the Fung Bros you know
it's gospel till next time Internet
check out this slurp
[Music]